yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a  job with peace  do we know each other  time  [Music]  reality reality  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question isn't it  every universe  is different  each one  you need  [Music]  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you  the name's captain carter  [Music]  i am the watcher  i observe all that transpires here  but i do not  cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  hey  we have you out of bed a ravager never  flies solo  i said never flies  solo ah  is that some kind of catchphrase  you had me wear it for a second  journey to face the unknown  and ponder the question  [Music]  what if  [Music]